do you know what they did to my brother
and my mother
I lie awake all night thinking about how
they died
what good is power if you cannot protect
the ones you love we can avenge them
well that time I was gone the world's
falling apart always keep your foes
confused if they don't know who you are
or what you want they can't know what
you plan to do next sometimes it is
better to answer injustice with mercy
I will answer injustice with justice
running out of time I will not become a
page in someone else's history book
you've had boys still walking its cause
you let her go
we were talking you're the mother of
dragons I need to be moving that
then can we trust ourselves alone
we mustn't disappoint father
we have done nothing wrong but don't
plenty wrong
hey youtubers is charlie and Game of
Thrones just posted a brand new trailer
for season three and it mostly just
highlights a lot of the impending
conflicts that are going to have this
season the big battles we also get some
new scenes from Sansa Cersei Oberyn
Martell Jon Snow and Barristan Selmy
Littlefinger also has a nice speech
although he got a bit of a voice over in
the last clip that they posted I love
that little fingers just talking about
playing the odds playing enemies against
each other and Barristan Selmy is really
like the voice of reason even though
Danny doesn't want to listen to him the
scenes that they cut together we're
actually from different episodes but
they work together really well
thematically danny has essentially
committed herself to freeing the slaves
of marine and then helping they lead a
better life hands-down favorite moments
from the trailers though are that giant
shot of her unsullied army as well as
the shot of the three dragons together
Jon Snow of course is always a welcome
addition and it seems like he is
determined to punish himself this season
for all the fun that he had with Egret
in that cave be sure to let me know what
your favorite moment was in the comments
below I'll be posting a full breakdown
tomorrow be sure to subscribe to get
that if you're finding me for the first
time and i'll be posting a Q&A video the
day after that too right now click here
to get that breakdown video and click
here to get that Q&A video thanks so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight high fives
you